- I'm in El Paso, Texas
outside the Sacred Heart Catholic Church
just across the border from Ciudad Juarez.
Officials here in El Paso
estimate as many as 2,500 people
have built an encampment in
and around this neighborhood,
primarily around this
church seeking refuge.
(Luz Maria speaks Spanish)
(soft music)
The migrant population has surged
in advance of the end of Title
42, the public health law
that has allowed the Trump administration
and now the Biden administration
to quickly expel many migrants
who have crossed the border illegally
before they can ask for
protections in the U.S.
Some of these migrants, an untold number,
actually crossed the
border without encountering
federal immigration officials
and are without papers at this point.
- I am declaring a state of
emergency in our community.
And the reason why we're declaring
a state of emergency is to
make sure that we can stand up
and be prepared for May 11th, May 12th
to have public sheltering, public housing.
- Rumors are rampant across the border
in Ciudad Juarez, according
to local officials here,
that if you can make it to the U.S.
by the 11th, you'll be fine.
That's not accurate.
Migrants without documentation
won't be able to leave the city,
and those encountered by the border patrol
still are subject as Title 42.
And after the 11th, many
will face swift removal
if they're not eligible
for asylum processes here in the U.S.
(Aracely speaks Spanish)
Once Title 42 does expire, the
U.S. government will go back
to processing people
under its normal order,
what's called Title 8.
With that comes swift removal
for those who don't qualify for asylum
and the possibility of bans
on returning to the United
States for up to five years,
and criminal charges, a
felony, if folks do come back.
This latest surge of migrants
here in the city of El Paso
mirrors one experienced in December,
the last time Title 42 was set to expire.
The difference now,
local officials tell me,
is there's more people.
- We figure that it's anywhere
between 10 to 12,000 people
that are ready to come
on May 11th, May 12th.
We do know that there's additional
coming right behind them.
- Right now, in the background
across the city of El Paso,
officials are building
out shelter capacity.
They're preparing a pair
of decommissioned schools
to eventually house several
hundred if not more migrants
expected in the area in the coming days.
(soft music)